when i was fighting the ufc i would  never let the doctor ever use any  painkiller anytime he had to stitch me  closed at strikeforce ifl wc ufc you  know like that proper doctors stitching  us up and matter of fact the i think his  hashtags like ufc doc he sews up  everybody and he tweets often about how  uncomfortable he was stitching me up  because i would sit there with my eyes  open as he's closing my cheek and he's  like no i'm gonna give you a local i'm  like you give me a local i'm just gonna  walk out and i'm gonna be the way that i  am or you can stitch me up and he's like  i never knew what to do with this dude  but then i just sit there and tim  wouldn't move and i'd sew his face  closed because i wanted to feel that  pain because i made a mistake in there  in the octagon and i didn't want to dull  the pain because there should be a  consequence for that pain and i wanted  to remember that pain in the future